bien ben mes chers collègues je vous
propose que nous entamions
notre réunion de de commission et donc
en l'absence du président pin qui est en
déplacement en Colombie je suis heureux
d'accueillir aujourd'hui David Colomb
qui est professeur agrégé d'histoire et
chercheur au Centre d'histoire de
sciencecesp et qui vient de publier un
ouvrage remarqué sur la guerre de
l'information Monsieur le professeur
bienvenue dans votre dernier livre vous
considérez que c'est une véritable
guerre informationnelle qui a commencé
vous affirmez même qu'une menace
mortelle pèse sur les démocraties depuis
une dizaine d'années maintenant on
observe des actions de
déstabilisation mené par des structures
étatiques et non étatiques dans les
grandes démocraties en France on peut
citer le piratage des système
informatique de TV5 Monde en 2015 la
création de médias proposant des contenu
alternatif on a en tête Russia Today qui
a joué un rôle dans la crise des gilets
jaunes des soutiens financiers apporté à
des mouvements politiques qui reprennent
à leur compte l'argumentaire des États
autoritaires en Afrique nous voyons
l'utilisation désormais systématique de
la désinformation des grands acteurs par
les grands acteurs extérieurs au
continent aux États-Unis on s'en
souvient ce sont les élections qui ont
été perturbé par des piratages de boî
mail ce phénomène a été constaté en
France également lors des élections
présidentielles vous datez d'ailleurs de
la campagne présidentielle de 2017 la
prise de conscience en France de
l'ampleur de la guerre informationnel
les indices étaient là devant nous
peut-être avons-nous sans doute
collectivement tardé à vraiment en
prendre conscience prendre conscience
des véritables stratégies mises en œuvre
vous évo ces stratégies globales
cohérentes
multidirectionnell déployé par les États
autoritaires pour afféblir les
démocraties occidentales vous analysez
notamment les actions de la Russie mais
vous citez aussi et c'est intéressant la
Chine l'Iran et la Corée du Nord vous
pourrez sans doute nous exposer le lien
entre la guerre informationnel et les
affrontements plus conventionnels y
compris sur les champs de bataille
comment les États autoritaires en
sont-ils venus à développer ces
stratégies quels sont leurs contours et
leur efficacité comment s'en prémunir et
aussi pardon comment répliquer sans
renoncer à notre tour aux libertés
démocratiques c'est probablement la
difficulté de l'exercice enfin vous
pourrez peut-être nous indiquer comment
nos partenaires et alliés répondent à
ces enjeux je pense en particulier pas
seulement mais en particulier aux
États-Unis qui ont compris avant les
autres l'importance du champ
informationnel voilà sans être plus long
monsieur le professeur je vous laisse
présenter votre analyse au cours d'un
propos liminaire et puis nos collègues
de la commission pourront vous
interroger je rappelle que cette
audition est capté et diffusé en direct
sur le site du Sénat je m'en réjouis car
je crois que votre audition aujourd'hui
a aussi un rôle d'information à
l'intention de nos compatriotes monsieur
le professeur vous avez la parole
Président Mesdames et
messieurses et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs sur le bouton
et monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs et les
sénatrices mesdames et messieurs je
voudrais d'abord vous remercier pour
votre invitation je suis très heureux de
pouvoir venir m'exprimer devant vous non
pour présenter un livre mais
effectivement pour traiter du sujet de
ce livre à savoir la guerre de
l'information qui à mes yeux caractérise
à mes yeux d'historiens caractérise non
seulement les 10 dernières années mais
en réalité la
période qui que nous avons connu depuis
la fin de la guerre froide c'est-à-dire
depuis qu'à l'équilibre de la guerre
froide a
succédé un déséquilibre qui est celui de
la guerre de l'information la guerre
froide était caractérisée par
l'opposition de deux modèles économiques
idéologiqu et par le recours à des
conflits périphérique et à la crainte du
conflit nucléaire la guerre de
l'information se caractérise par des
conflits directs mais endessà du seuil
de conflictualité ouvert par le recours
à l'information comme à une arme aussi
bien dans l'espace médiatique
traditionnel que dans l'espace
cybernétique le bouleversement introduit
par la fin de la guerre froide en
réalité est en effet lié à l'avèement
des systèmes d'information numérique et
à leur utilisation aussi bien dans un
champ militaire que dans un champ
médiatique et civil il est lié aussi à
l'avènement de de médias planétaire à
l'image de CNN il est lié aussi et je
dois le dire pour commencer à une
volonté quelque peu hégémonique des
États-Unis en matière d'information à la
fin de la guerre froide volonté
hégémonique qui s'est traduite en
1991 par le recours à l'information
comme à une arme aussi bien sur le champ
de bataille pour des opérations
d'information pour des opérations de
cybergerre pour également des opérations
visant à permettre aux soldats
américains de disposer d'une d'un
contrôle de l'espace informationnel sur
le champ de bataille mais aussi une
domination informationnelle dans le
champ médiatique global pour faire
prévaloir le point de vue des États-Unis
et par la suite cela a conduit à une
évolution très profonde de la doctrine
des États-Unis par exemple avec
l'avénement de ce que l'on a appelé
Joseph na a appelé le soft power qui en
est une conséquence directe où l'on
promeut son pays à travers ses valeurs
ses symboles sa culture à travers la
naissance de la cyberguerre le mot nî à
ce moment-là et traduit à la fois les
actions dans le cyberespace mené par des
pirates informatiques et des soldats
cybergerriers mais aussi la guerre du
net la guerre d'Internet c'est-à-dire la
volonté des États à commencé par les
États-Unis de faire prévaloir leur récit
dans ce nouvel espace d'information et
de communication qui échappe au cadre
traditionnel réguler des médias dans un
régime démocratique comme dans un régime
autoritaire et cette volonté de
domination de l'information a été perçu
on le sait aujourd'hui de façon très
nette par un certain nombre de rég de
régimes comme une menace existentielle
cela a été perçu comme une menace
existentielle pour le régime russe qui a
vu certes la disparition de l'URSS et du
Parti communiste mais pas la disparition
des services de renseignement qui depuis
1918 pour le renseignement militaire
russe et depuis 1954 pour le KGB devenu
FSB et SVR ont poursuivi sur la longue
durée une entreprise qui était résumée
par une formule de Rolf wagenbreet
prononcé en 1986 à dresd dresd O certain
Vladimir Poutine était alors agent de
liaison du KGB auprès de l'ashetasie il
s'agissait d'un travail de décomposition
des soci é adverse travail qui se
poursuit je vais revenir dans un instant
la menace a été également perçue comme
vitale existentielle par le régime
chinois on sait aujourd'hui que le
président Yang Zemin devant des cadres
du renseignement civil en 1993 a dénoncé
je cite la guerre mondiale sans fumée
qui selon lui était menée par les
États-Unis de la même façon que les
dirigeants du renseignement extérieur
russe voyaient la main des États-Unis
dans la chute de l'
RSS les dirigeants de Pékin voyaient la
main des États-Unis dans les événements
du Printemps de Pékin et voyaient dans
l'essort des médias planétaires une
menace pour la stabilité de leur régime
ce qui a conduit ces régimes
autoritaires et d'autres que vous avez
cité monsieur le Président l'Iran la
Corée du Nord a adopté des mesures de
protection de leur espace informationnel
à l'égard d'ingérence étrangère on
interdit les antennes satellites on
interdit les médias étrangers on compte
ôle l'information qui circule à
destination de ces citoyens mais cela
les a conduit également à se doter de
ces nouveaux attribut de la puissance à
l'ARE informationnelle que sont le soft
power la Chine a été le premier pays au
monde à se réapproprier le soft power
sous le nom de Ruan Chili en
1993 la Russie l'a fait par la voix de
Vladimir Poutine c'est la Makaya Sila je
crois pardonnez mon russe en en 2013 ils
se sont dotés aussi d'équipe de ha cœur
de cybergerriers pour faire face à la
menace que représentait à leurs yeux les
équipes de cybergerriers de la NSA et
des actions offensives ils se sont dotés
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président de
médias internationaux pour dans un
premier temps porter leur voix sur la
scène internationale et dans un second
temps affaiblir la voix de nos démocrati
et fragiliser nos démocraties de
l'intérieur et depuis l'avèement des
téléphones portables de depuis
l'avèement des réseaux sociaux ils ont
perçu la menace comme particulièrement
accentuée je crois que le tournant
majeur en ce qui concerne la Russie se
situe en décembre 2011 lorsque à la
suite des printemps arabes souvent
qualifié de révolution Twitter ou de
révolution
2.0 le président pardon le Premier
ministre Vladimir Poutine a perçu dans
les manifestations moscovite la main de
la la CIA a considéré que les États-Unis
avaient l'intention de recourir à
l'information numérique sur les réseaux
sociaux qui étit alors tout à fait
nouveaux pour renverser son pouvoir
provoquer un changement de régime et il
craignait plusieurs sources la teste de
finir aussi tragiquement qu'à fini ses
jours monsieur Kaddafi ce qui en retour
a conduit dans les années qui ont suivi
une militarisation des espaces
informationnels numériques c'est-à-dire
la transformation en armes de ce qui
étaient des outils d'information et qui
étaient perçus par ces régimes
autoritaires comme une menace pour la
stabilité de leur régime il en va de
même pour le président sijinping
lorsqu'il accède au pouvoir au lendemain
de l' sort sur les médias sociaux
chinois d'une contestation inédite dans
l'histoire de la Chine à la suite du
tremblement de terre du Schang
contestation des dirigeants des
fonctionnaire contestation du régime
politique qui a conduit en retour à
l'adoption par la Chine de mesures de
contrôle de son espace informationnel
qui sont en tout point comparables aux
mesures prises par la Russie vous savez
Charles Py Charles pegy disait il faut
dire ce que l'on voit surtout il faut
toujours ce qui est plus difficile voir
ce que l'on voit beaucoup de choses ont
été vues mais beaucoup ont refusé de
voir ce qu'ils voyait parce que
voulaient voir au contraire dans les
échanges avec ces régimes autoritaires
dans le discours porté par certains
dirigeants de ces régimes autoritaires
une promesse de changement une promesse
de
démocratisation je cite dans mon livre
ce discours de Bill Clinton à
l'Université de Pékin en 1998 qui
aujourd'hui apparaît d'une
extraordinaire naïveté lorsque devant
les dirigeants du Parti communiste il
explique qu'après 4 jours de visite des
villages en Chine il avait vu
l'information circuler librement il
avait vu les téléphones portables
permettre à des villageois de
s'organiser de se doter de leur propres
syndicat de se doter de leur propre
système électoral de procéder eux même à
leur liber à leurs élections il avait vu
un vent de liberté sur la Chine et au
retour dans l'avion il glisse à
l'oreille du correspondant du New York
Times qui l'accompagnait qu'il était
convaincu que ce que les Américains
appellent le free flow of information la
libre circulation de l'information
allait conduire à l'effondrement du
Parti communiste chinois et ce à quoi
nous assistons aujourd'hui c'est non
seulement au fait que le Parti
communiste chinois ne s'est pas effondré
mais que le Parti communiste chinois
c'est en l'espace de 20 ans depuis
l'adoption par l'Armée populaire de
libération de la doctrine dite des trois
guerres doté du plus grand appareil de
renseignement au monde plus grand
appareil de renseignement de l'histoire
il s'est doté de la plus grande cyber
armée au monde il s'est doté des plus
grandes équipes de cyber mercenaires il
s'est doté d'outils stratégiques lui
permet per mettant de porter sa
supériorité informationnelle pardelà ses
frontières il s'est doté d'outils de
communication que non pas d'autres
régimes autoritaires la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine a pu instrumentaliser
comme je le raconte les systèmes
publicitaire de Facebook pour semer le
chaos aux États-Unis et interférer avec
les élections mais le kremelin ne
dispose pas n'a jamais disposé de
l'équivalent de TikTok qui est
aujourd'hui une arme redoutable entre
les mains d'un régime autoritaire qui
peut interférer directement avec le
cerveau de milliards de personnes sur la
planète au profit de ces ambitions
géostratégiques je ne vais pas vous
mentir mon anxiété était grande en
écrivant ce livre et je n'ai je ne
prends aucun plaisir à exprimer de
l'anxiété ni à transmettre de l'anxiété
mais j'ai pour habitude de chercher à
voir ce que je vois et à le présenter au
au plus grand nombre à charge pour ce
plus grand nombre de prendre conscience
et surtout de réagir de la façon
appropriée j'ai conscience que nos
adversaires ont une stratégie de très
long terme qui est une stratégie je le
disais tout à l'heure de décomposition
il s'agit de décomposer la société
adverse en affaiblissant ce qui fait sa
cohésion ce qui fait notre cohésion dans
une société démocratique c'est d'abord
la confiance dans nos institutions la
confiance dans notre personnel politique
la confiance dans nos institutions dans
notre personnel administratif la
confiance dans nos médias la confiance
quant à l'information à la crédibilité à
la valeur de l'information qui nous
parvient et c'est précisément tout cela
qui est visé depuis longtemps par ces
services de renseignement qui sur la
durée font le même travail qu'il faisait
autrefois mais avec des outils nouveaux
vous savez quand vous regardez le
Conseil de sécurité restreint de la
Fédération de Russie ils sont une petite
dizaine et CIN au moins parmi eux sont
des anciens du KGB qui comme Vladimir
Poutine sont entrés au KGB dans les
années 1970 qui comme lui pour beaucoup
sont passés par le premier directorat
c'est-à-dire le renseignement extérieur
du KGB qui pour beaucoup comme Poutine
ont été formé de main de maître à l'art
de la manipulation de la subversion et
de la propagande par yy Andropov qui
avait coutume de dire que la meilleure
des informations était celle qui
trouvait ses propres relais que l'on
avait pas besoin de soutenir à bout de
bras qui prenaient prise dans un
environnement donné et trouvait des
élateurs qui volontairement allaient
amplifier son contenu et conduire à ce
que andropof et les autres appelaient un
virus médiatique et ce que les Russes
désormais enfin les stratèges russes de
la désinformation ont coutume d'appeler
un virus psychologique qui à la manière
d'un virus humain a besoin d'un autre il
se transmet d'humain en humain qui à la
manière d'un virus s'il n'est pas
détecté par un test peut infecter un
grand nombre de personnes avant que l'on
constate les effets produits par ce
virus qui peut se répliquer de lui-même
mais là non pas d'humain à humain mais
d'esprit à esprit par-delà les océans
par-delà les frontières grâce aux outils
numériques qui permettent une
amplification démesurée les
épidémologistes se penchaient sur le R0
et se penchent encore sur le R0
on peut contaminer 10 15 personnes un
virus informationnel peut en contaminer
256 à la fois sur snapchat en 2016 et
ces 256 vont en infecter 256 qui vont
rapidement devenir des millions nous
avons affaire à quelque chose qui croit
cette ce virus de la désinformation
parce que notre système immunitaire a
été systématiquement ciblé par les
adversaires de nos démocraties qui en
fragilisant la distinction entre le vrai
et le faux la crédibilité de ceux qui
ont pour fonction d'établir ce qui est
vrai et ce qui est faux ont favorisé la
croyance en des théories parfois
absurdes quand on songe qu'il y a
aujourd'hui 7 millions de personnes au
moins aux États-Unis qui affirment que
la terre est plate et pire encore il y
en a 23 millions qui à la question la
Terre est-elle ronde répondent je ne
sais pas nous sommes en présence de la
déstabilisation profonde non seulement
des fondements de notre cohésion sociale
à travers l'instrumentalisation du chaos
l'exploitation de toutes les failles de
nos sociétés les ingérences électorales
la guerre psychologique la guerre
cognitive mais nous sommes confrontés au
pire danger qui soit qui est
l'affaiblissement de notre régime de
vérité je voudrais pour terminer cette
introduction trop longue et je vous prie
de m'en excuser citer un autre auteur
qui m'écher qui est Marc bloc qui dans
l'étrange défaite revenait sur la
responsabilité des médias français dans
la défaite et dans l'esprit de défaite
qui avait pu gagner nos concitoyens en
1940 il s'interrogeait en particulier
sur les influences étrangères fascistes
naz soviétique notre presse était
perméable à ces influences étrangères et
il se demandait ce que nous avions fait
pour donner à ce peuple français ce je
cite minimum de renseignement net et sûr
sans lequel aucune conduite rationnelle
n'est possible ce qui est aujourd'hui
visé fondamentalement et sur la longue
durée par nos adversaires les régimes
autoritaires qui veulent faire
s'effondrer un certain nombre de nos
régimes démocratiques c'est ce que
Michel fouco appelit le régime de vérité
ce régime qui permet l'énonciation de
faits partagés qui permet la distinction
entre le vrai et le faux et qui permet
surtout à nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyennes d'avoir seulement la
possibilité d'avoir une conduite
rationnelle et ce que nous devons je
crois collectivement défendre
aujourd'hui c'est cette capacité pour
nos concitoyens de disposer d'une
information intègre nette sûre qui
garantisse une conduite rationnelle dans
le respect vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président de ce qui fonde à la fois la
faiblesse intrinsèque et la force de nos
démocratie à savoir le fait que nous
sommes des sociétés ouvertes que nous
sommes des sociétés de liberté liberté
d'expression liberté de réunion liberté
d'association liberté d'informer liberté
d'opinion et que toute atteinte à ces
libertés au nom de la lutte contre les
manipulations de l'information n'a pour
effet que de conforter le scepticisme et
la défiance de ceux qui en souffrent
déjà et de conforter le discours de nos
adversaires qui ont beau jeu alors de
comparer notre attitude à la propre
attitude qui est l' leur à l'égard par
exemple de leurs opposants ou de leurs
minorités je conclus le livre par ces
mots d'un poète allemand Fredrich Erlin
là où croit le péril croit aussi ce qui
sauve je suis convaincu que la prise de
conscience dont cette audition est à mes
yeux l'expression et le plus sûr moyen
pour nos démocraties de faire face aux
enjeux de l'année 2024 qui sera une
année difficile pour nous tous merci
beaucoup merci à vous pour ces propos
préliminaires on va rentrer dans la
phase questionréponse j'ai quatre
demandes de parole mais il peut y en
avoir d'autres je vous propose que on
fasse question réponse une question une
réponse au fil de l'eau première
question c'est François
bonau merci
président merci merci Monsieur pour la
clarté de vos propos sur les les menaces
virales du
monde avec plus de 200 million
d'utilisateurs actifs chat GPT c'est
c'est imposé comme un acteur de de masse
dans dans l' Converse
conversationnel pardon on peut
considérer que qui compte prendrait le
contrôle de l'architecture neuronale de
cette intelligence artificielle pourrait
orienter les les réponses produites à
des fins politiques voire idéologiques
certains chercheurs recommandent
d'investir massivement dans les
technologies de reconnaissan
stylométrique et de tournure
linguistique redondante afin de détecter
les productions pures de l'intelligence
artificielle quels sont selon vous les
outils adéquates pour encadrer
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle afin en préserver les
bienfaits tout en bannissant les les
pratiques
malveillantes bien évidemment très
réelles merci pour votre question
effectivement c'est un enjeu essentiel
que celui de l'intelligence artificielle
qui est un enjeu qui ne se limite pas à
la génération de faux contenus qui est
ce qui intéresse le plus la discussion
publique actuellement mais il y a
beaucoup de choses que l'on ne voit pas
aisément qui sont beaucoup plus
dommageables à nos démocraties notamment
le recours à des outils d'intelligence
artifici officiel pour détecter
automatiquement des failles dans nos
systèmes d'information des failles
qu'exploitent par exemple des pirates
informatiques pour perturber le
fonctionnement de système adverse et le
gardien a a révélé il y a de jours la
pénétration de de système d'une centrale
nucléaire britannique par des hackurs
agissant pour la Chine et la Russie
c'est détection des failles ne se limite
pas au
système structurel mais également aux
failles de nos prix et l'une des
particularités de l'intelligence
artificielle telle qu'elle est utilisée
aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà par les
plateformes numérique quel qu'elle soit
et l'exploitation de l'analyse
prédictive de la personnalité à des fins
de microciiblage publicitaire et parfois
d'exploitation subversives des failles
de nos esprits par certains acteurs
malveillants pour produire des effets
parfois dommageables pour nos société il
y a enfin euh cette question de la
génération de faux contenus qui pose un
problème systémique dans la mesure où
les progrès de l'intelligence
artificielle sont des progrès
exponentiels qui nécessairement devrait
conduire prochainement à une situation
fort désagréable dans laquelle le faux
primera Quan quantitativement sur le
vrai dans l'environnement informationnel
ce qui aura des effets en retour tous
les systèmes par exemple les systèmes de
moteur de recherche qui repose sur une
approche inductive c'est-à-dire
statistiquement des termine le vrai en
fonction de ce l'information qui domine
la terre est ronde parce que la plupart
des gens sur Internet affirme qu'elle
est ronde si un
jour l'information selon laquelle elle
est plate domine un système de ce type
pourrait à une question posée par un
utilisateur répondre bien sûr la terre
est plate pu autrement dit c'est ce
problème est systémique je crains pour
ma part que toute approche
autorégulatrice soit voué à l'échec
comme ont été voué à l'échec les
approches
autorégulatrice engagé par la Commission
européenne à l'égard de la diffusion de
la désinformation sur les plateformes
numériques en décembre
2018 je constate que l'approche
réglementaire du DSA là où elle a été
implémentée ne donne pas les résultats
escomtés et ne peut pas apporter de
réponse en temps réel à au danger
représenté par la menace dans la mesure
où tous les chercheurs en matière de
désinformation s'accordent à dire que
l'information la désinformation a
produit ses effets lorsqu'elle a été
diffusée vous pouvez ensuite démentir
une fausse information elle laissera des
traces vous pouvez chercher à démentir
une fausse information auprès de gens
qui pensent que la terre est plate vous
les conforterez dans l'idée que la terre
est plate parce qu'il considèeront que
c'est louche si vous cherchez à les
convaincre du contraire autrement dit
j'ai pour pour ma part une autre
approche qui consiste à envisager plutôt
de privilégier un espace intègre en
matière informationnelle dans le domaine
numérique pourquoi ne pas considérer un
espace dans lequel pourraient interagir
des internautes sans modèles publicitair
qui exploiteraient leur leur fragilité
psychique et donne rprise à des
influenceurs notamment étranger
malveillant pourquoi ne pas envisager un
système qui ne permettrait pas non plus
l'amplification artificielle des
contenus ni le recours à l'intelligence
artificielle autrement dit un système
proprement humain
d'information qui offrirait des
garanties d'intégrité pour ses
utilisateurs il me semble que c'est une
voie qui a trop peu été envisagé et qui
n'est pas la moins difficile à mettre en
œuvre si l'on considère les possibilités
techniques de certaines pl comme blue
sky qui sont des plateformes
décentralisées qui pourrai par
exemple si la Commission européenne
s'orienter dans cette direction
permettre à tous les utilisateurs
européens de bénéficier d'un espace
intègre respectueux en soi par
définition des règlements européens en
vigueur et qui ne poseraient pas les
mêmes risques systémiques pardon pour
cette réponse très longue merci pour la
réponse la parole est à Roger
carucci oui professeur
euh bon les ingérances étrangères c'est
vieux comme le monde oui euh en 194
Benito Mussolini qui possédait un
journal en Italie il Popolo d'Italia
recevait de l'argent des services
secrets français et anglais pour pousser
l'ital à rentrre en guerre dans l'entre
de guerre l'œuvre française je suis
partout oui recevez de l'argent des
nazis et des fascistes italiens pour
faire justement la propagande de de ces
pays et d'un changement de politique
française donc c'est pas récent euh
soyons franc après la deuxème Guerre
mondiale les Soviétiques d'un côté la
CIA de l'autre côté ont financé des
syndicats des journaux en France et
ailleurs donc c'est pas nouveau je
l'ingérence étrangère c'est un élément
de politique étrangère depuis des
siècles je dirais presque depuis des
millénaires j'ai quelques souvenirs dans
mes études d'avoir vu que Athène ne se
privait pas payer certains services à
spart donc c'est pas nouveau mais ce qui
a changé c'est le contact direct c'est
qu'avec le le le système des réseaux en
réalité on ne peut plus trouver un
responsable nos services d'enquête ne
peuvent plus annoncer qu'on est en
examen tel ou tel parce qu'il a reçu de
l'argent des services étrangers
maintenant le service étranger a un
accès direct à des millions de personnes
en même temps et là on ne sait plus trop
comment réagir alors vous avez raison le
premier élément c'est probablement
que les citoyens retrouvent confiance
ou crédit dans la parole publique dans
leur propre pays ou dans leurs médias
dans leur propre pays parce que dès
qu'ils n'ont plus confiance
euh forcément l'ingérence étrangère est
plus forte et en tout cas elle a plus
d'impact mais alors j'entends bien ce
que vous dites sur pourquoi ne pas
développer secteur intègre sans
publicité c'est probablement une arme
clair mais est-ce que nos gouvernants ne
sont pas en réalité aussi coupables de
ne pas être capable de défendre la
démocratie avec mon cher
collègue nous nous allons on
présenté le budget qu'on apprécie qu'on
approuve enfin qu'on apprécie pas mais
qu'on approuve sur les médias extérieur
de la France on est extrêmement rêveur
naïf on met 3 francs 6 sous de crédit
sur notre nos médias extérieurs alors
que on se fait promener en Afrique on se
fait promener au prochorient se promener
partout euh et on continue de penser
qu'avec trois machins on va on va
trouver la solution il est clair que
face aux dictatures ou face aux régimes
autoritaires que je refuse d'appeler le
je CIS quoi le sud global appellation qu
d'or c'est stupide s'il en est devant
l'éternel mais enfin bon laissons cela
mais est-ce que parce que vous vous
parlez de l'importance de l'ingérence
étrangère mais est-ce que c'est pas
d'abord la
faiblesse de notre réaction de nos
régimes la démocratie ça ne se défend
pas que par la parole
est-ce que là-dessus on ne devrait pas
être plus plus fort
dans la présence de de médias extérieur
qu'il soit d'ailleurs français
britannique américain c'estàd est-ce que
les pays démocratiques ne sont pas
faibles face à des offensives chinoises
russes ou autres dans dans le domaine
des médias avant même de l'être dans le
domaine de
l'Internet professeur à vous merci
monsieur le sénateur pour votre question
la la force de notre société ce sont ces
valeurs et ce sont ces valeurs que nous
devons défendre pour rester
attrayant dans le
monde vous avez tout à fait raison de
souligner que l'influence étrangère
n'est pas nouvelle et que ce qui est
nouveau c'est
sa portée qui est sans commune mesure
avec ce qui a été connu
jusqu'à présent en ce qui concerne les
moyens que l'on peut mettre en œuvre il
me semble que le
premier à mettre en œuvre est la
transparence nous avons besoin de mettre
en évidence aux yeux du plus grand
nombre la réalité de ces ingérences
étrangères pour cela une proposition qui
a été je crois faite par l'un de nos
services de renseignement et qui me
paraît parfaitement judicieuse c'est
l'adoption d'une loi comparable à celle
qui existe depuis 1938 aux États-Unis et
qui fait obligation à quiconque mène une
action d'influence à l'intérieur de
notre territoire pour le compte d'un
agent étranger étatique ou non étatique
de déclarer son activité il s'agit pas
d'une loi liberticide comme l'est la loi
sur les agents étrangers du kremelin qui
une fois que quelqu'un est qualifié
d'agent étranger lui
vaut les pires choses là il s'agit d'une
loi de de transparence pour rendre
visible au plus grand nombre ce qui se
passe en matière d'ingérence quantifieré
l'ingérence des différents pays
autoritaires comme non autoritaire du
reste quant à leur volonté de faire
prévaloir un certain nombre de récits il
y a tentation de certains pays par
exemple de fragiliser le soutien de
notre opinion publique envers le
rayonnement de la France en Afrique et
dans l'océan Indien cela doit être rendu
visible euh au plus grand nombre pour
que la société s'en empare et que ce ne
soit pas le monopole de nos services
voué à la défense et la protection de
notre souveraineté en même temps parmi
ces services il me semble que il est
aujourd'hui plus que nécessaire de
renforcer et de doter plus
considérablement ceux qui sont en
première ligne de cette guerre de
l'information et qui ont fait la preuve
de leur efficacité je pense en premier
lieu bien évidemment à viginum je pense
en premier lieu à la sous-direction du
kéorset en charge de ces questions
stratégiques de la veille et de la
ripost ils sont de mon point de vue de
chercheur sous-dotés sous-équipés cont
tenu de la menace et à la veille d'une
année électorale et à la veille d'une
année marquée par les jeux ollympique
qui vont être un peu le sur le
supermarché mondial de gérance et de la
déstabilisation il est plus qu'urgent
aujourd'hui de leur donner les moyens de
faire face à cette menace enfin euh
s'agissant de nos médias de servicees
publics il est bon de rappeler qu'ils
sont des médias de service public et non
des médias d'État qu'ils ne sont pas aux
ordres du pouvoir exécutif et ne sont
pas là pour porter la voix de tel ou tel
membre de l'exécutif mais de porter la
voix de l'intérêt général bien
évidemment aussi la voix de la France
mais sans recourir à la manipulation
comme le font d'autres médias qui sont
des médias
d'État et dont les rédacteurs en chef
sononore eux-mêmes publiquement d'être
je les cite des guerriers de
l'information le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon pour obéir aux ordres de leurs
autorités politiques il faut investir
dans le journalisme de qualité vous
savez je vois aussi dans nos médias
internationaux des journalistes
extraordinairement valeureux qui font
face à des campagnes de déstabilisation
qui parfois les visent eux-mêmes qui
sont d'une brutalité inouï qui font face
à une croissance exponentielle de la
désinformation avec peu de moyens ils
ont besoin aujourd'hui d'être aidés et
puis nous avons besoin de renforcer
l'immunité de notre société face à ces
ingérences par le renforcement du
journalisme de qualité ce que j'appelle
le journalisme de qualité c'est le
journalisme qui répond à une à une
démarche déontologique et éthique qui
s'engage à suivre cette démarche et qui
par exemple dans le cadre actuel de ce
qui existe adhère à la démarche de
reporter sans frontière qui s'appelle
GTI journalism trust initiative et qui
voit ses journaux s'engager à respecter
ses règles déontologiques accepter un
audit extérieur pour pour vérifier
qu'ils assur bien cela et nous pourrions
envisager de réorienter une partie des
aides publiques à la presse en priorité
vers ce journalisme de qualité nous
pourrions envisager de contraindre les
plateformes numériques à amplifier la
portée de ce journalisme de qualité il
ne s'agit pas de stigmatiser l'autre
journalisme il s'agit d'encourager ce
journalisme de qualité et
potentiellement de confiance pardon
encore une fois pour cette réponse très
longue Olivier
cadiic
oui merci beaucoup effectivement très
très
intéressant nous avons reçu un
spécialiste de l'OTAN qui nous a qui
combat les trolls et qui nous a montré
que en fait le temps moyen pour lire une
news est de 7 secondes donc
effectivement les technologies de la de
manipulation ne sont pas nouvelles comme
l'a dit notre
collègue mais surtout le vrai le faux
tout dépend l'idée qu'on s'en fait
et chacun a sa vérité apparaît le
concept de vérité alternative donc en
fait l'objet c'est de créer la confusion
dans les esprits c'est ça que cherche à
faire en fait les les les Russes souvent
et vous avez raison une fake news est
réussi à partir du moment où elle est
disséminée et je vrais rappeler quand
même que le mariage du buounti au Mali a
été quand même le plus grand cas d'école
puisqueaujourd'hui encore vous tapez sur
les réseaux sociaux et vous allez tout
sur les moteurs de recherche et vous
allez voir ça comme un fait avérer alors
que personne n'a jamais vu une photo du
mariage ni des mariés donc on sait même
pas de quoi il s'agit mais toujours
est-il que ça a fait son effet euh ce
qui me gêne un petit peu enfin ce que je
je comprends j'apprécie tous vos propos
mais euh mais j'ai l'impression que en
fait tout n'est que défensif dans ce qui
euh dans dans la réaction euh qu'on
devrait avoir en disant on va on va
donner une information de qualité
essayer de la la rendre intègre mais
tout ça en fait c'est une réaction par
rapport à ce qui nous
arrive Taïwan travaille cette question
fortement d'ailleurs ils ont développé
tout un un modèle de réponse donc
faisant en sorte que la communauté
justement la collectivité soit participe
à la réaction avec des réponses à une
fake new en 2 Hees en utilisant le
l'humour mais tout ça n'est que de la
défense est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
Prigogine en fait quelque part nous a
montré la voie pour
déstabiliser la Russie est-ce que quels
sont les points faibles de la Chine et
de la Russie pour le pour sur lesquels
nous pourrions travailler et être de
notre côté un petit peu offensif
merci merci monsieur le sénateur pour
votre question euh j'insiste sur
l'aspect défensif dans la mesure où je
sais que l'aspect offensif a fait
l'objet d'investissement important
depuis longtemps il y a longtemps que
nos armées ont pris conscience de la
menace de la propagande djihadiste euh
que l'amiral coustillère a constitué une
équipe et a mené des actions de
contre-discours la France est dotée d'un
d'un come cyber qui est un modèle
international de ce qui peut-être fait
pour porter le combat au-delà de nos
frontières mais vous aurez compris que
si je je n'évoque pas l'aspect offensif
c'est parce que ma priorité en tant que
cher chur et auteur de ce
livre c'est de
préserver la sérénité de DOB
démocratique de préserver notre
démocratie de préserver nos libertés
face à des ingérences étrangères auquel
on n'oppose pas toujours une réponse
adaptée je vais vous parler comme je
crois le faire sans langue de bois vous
citez Taïwan l'approche de taiïwan est
une approche horizontale c'est-à-dire
que l'ensemble de la société pour
commencer est consciente de la menace
l'ensemble de la société a accès à des
informations factuelles sur l'état de la
menace l'ensemble de la société est
éduqué non pas au médias de façon
générale mais à la désinformation
comment la détecter et comment s'en
prémunir l'ensemble de la société est
mobilisé dans une démarche qui relève de
ce que j'appelle dans le livre La
Défense
informationnelle en France nous avons
une approche en silo une approche en
tuyau d'org nous avons des services qui
ne collaborent pas toujours suffisamment
entre eux et nous avons une tendance
assez lourde à privilégier le secret
pour tout ce qui relève des questions
dont nous traitons ce matin et cette
tendance nous est préjudiciable dans la
mesure où souvent elle nous conduit à ne
pas appréhender
les opérations d'ingérance à l'échelle
qui est la leure permettez-moi de donner
un exemple récent ces moldaves qui ont
dessiné sur les murs des étoiles de
David vous avez d'un côté le volet
judiciaire et sécuritaire vous avez de
l'autre le volet de l'amplification
artificielle sur Twitter pour porter
cela à la connaissance des journalistes
vous avez ensuite le volet médiatique
avec l'absence de formation des
journalistes à ce type d'opération de
déstabilisation dont ils sont couramment
la cible et tout ça est traité de façon
dispersée monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure vous évoquiez ce que les
États-Unis on ont fait la principale
réalisation des États-Unis a été en la
matière le jack le Global engagement
Center le centre d'engagement global
comme son nom l'indique il appréhende la
menace à l'échelle globale c'est-à-dire
que il unit des personnels du Pentagone
donc des militaires à des personnels
civils du Département d'État à des
personnels de la communauté du
renseignement c'estàd 15 services de
renseignement principaux des États-Unis
aux représentants des médias
internationaux qui sont associés à la
discussion à un écosystème de chercheurs
à un écosystème d'industriel qui aussi
prennent part à cette dimension et nous
avons besoin d'une même approche globale
enfin permettez-moi une dernière
remarque puisque que j'ai j'ai été
invité par le com cyber à m'exprimer
récemment à Rennes à l'occasion de la
cyber week et j'ai fait le tour de notre
industrie en matière de cyberdéfense
j'ai fait je ne citerai aucune industrie
aucun industriel mais j'ai été frappé
par le fait que nous disposons vraiment
d'industriel remarqua qui proposeent
tout ce qu'il faut en matière de défense
de nos systèmes d'information vraiment
la France est un pays leader dans le
monde en matière de cybersécurité nous
avons une industrie remarquable que
proposent ces industriels en matière de
de de pour pour pour la dernière faille
de sécurité qui se situe entre la chaise
et l'ordinateur c'est-à-dire l'être
humain qui va cliquer sur le lien sur
lequel il ne va pas il devrait pas
cliquer l'être humain qui va relayer le
l'information qu'il ne devrait pas
relayer l'être humain qui recevant une
information va réagir par un acte de
colère et dans certains cas passer à
l'acte un acte délictuel ou criminel à
l'heure actuelle nous ne proposons rien
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il me
paraît aujourd'hui plus que jamais
nécessaire d'engager une démarche de
défense informationnelle pour
sensibiliser nos concitoyens à la menace
les doter des outils de percevoir la
menace de voir ce qu'il voi d'agir en
conséquence doter aussi nos services et
notre armée des moyens d'établir des
liens consubstantiels non seulement avec
les industrie de défense mais avec tous
les citoyens et tous les citoyennes qui
sont préoccupés par ces questions et
adopter cette démarche défensive qui
nous permettra d'affronter la menace qui
se présente devant nous et qui ne va pas
malheureusement dans un temps prochain
décroîre je suis encore une fois désolé
de vous répondre si longuement Claude
maluré merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Professeur je crois que votre livre est
un livre de salubrité publique un livre
trop rare d'ailleurs
euh et je suis bien entendu entièrement
d'accord avec vous je voudrais peut-être
faire quelques remarque la première
c'est que vous datez il faut toujours
dater les les les les études que l'on
fait de d'un certain moment vous le
datez de la fin de la période de la
guerre froide je remonterai pas jusqu'à
spart et athè comme Roger kouci le
faisait tout à l'heure mais je dirais
que nous avons un retard d'un siècle en
fait nous n'avons pas seulement un
retard de quelques décennies nous avons
un retard d'un siècle euh ce
sujet le sujet de la désinformation le
sujet de l'infiltration le sujet des 5e
colonnes Roger y a fait allusion tout à
l'heure il a commencé en 1917 avec la
création de la Teka et du nkavd et nous
avons eu des périodes et je suis
d'accord avec lui là-dessus peut-être
encore plus difficiles et plus
dangereuses euh et et et la première de
ces de de de comment dire de ces de ces
ces tentatives c'était la tentative la
plus qui a duré presque un siècle qui a
duré 70 ans c'était les partis la
création des partis communistes nous
avons vécu dans les sociétés démocraties
et particulièrement en France et en
Europe avec le principal outil de
désinformation qui étaient les partis
communiste et qui était largement d'une
nuisance aussi grande que celle des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui nous avons
vécu avec le Mouvement de la Paix qui a
désarmé qui a notamment désarmé la
France mais qui a désarmé beaucoup de de
démocratie euh je je cite une anecdote
dans les années 80 quand j'étais
président de frentière on travaillit
avec solidarnosque nous avons solidarnos
nous révéé ce que d'ailleurs la
direction du Figaro savait que le
correspondant du Figaro à Varsovie et
que le correspondant du Figaro à Moscou
étaiit des agents du du du KGB et cl
retrouvé ça très bien parce que ça leur
permettait d'avoir des renseignements de
première main mais c'est c'était c'était
déjà comme ça à cette échelle alors une
première une et d'ailleurs deuxème
période difficile je vous rappelle que
Revel écrivait à la fin des années 70 en
1980 comment les démocraties finissent
c'était l'époque de Carter des otages
américains en Iran c'était l'époque où
les Russes Soviétiques étaient en
Afghanistan en était en train de en
héritrée Éthiopie aujourd'hui on dit le
Mali Niger et cetera il s'était déjà en
train de conquérir une bonne partie de
l'Afrique et de nous en et de nous en
chasser ou de chasser les les
Occidentaux euh comment ça s'est terminé
ça s'est pas terminé parce qu'on a gagné
la guerre de laance s cette guerre ou la
guerre des des renseignements le bouquin
de Robert little la compagnie et
probablement moi je le recommande à tout
le monde ici à ceux qui ne l'ont pas lu
c'est l'histoire de la guerre entre la
CIA et le KGB sur le plan de
l'information et du renseignement le KGB
l'a gagné cette guerre et et et de très
loin comment elle s'est terminé elle
s'est terminée parce qu'un
jour contre tous les courants un homme a
eu la volonté un homme qu'on présente
ici et notamment en Europe comme un
semiemeuré qui est a été un des plus
grands présidents des États-Unis en
définitive a décidé que on allait en
terminer par la volonté politique et
après Carter Rean est arrivé qui c'est
c'est Rean qui a mis l'URSS à genou et
qui a entraîné la par la guerre des
étoiles la fin de l'URSS c'est donc pas
un problème de renseignement c'est un
problème de volonté politique que
évidemment nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
évidemment évidemment alors ça ça
m'amène à ma à ma deuxème remarque c'est
celle sur la
naïveté j'ai demandé ici au Sénat en
2018 à Cédric
ha à l'époque ministre chargé du
numérique l'interdiction de RT et de
Sputnik je me suis fait renvoyer dans
mes buts certains s'en souviennent
peut-être au nom de la liberté
d'expression j'expliquais quetptique
était évidemment pas des médias que
c'était fabriqué directement au
directorat d du
FSB que bon je je vais pas plus loin et
que évidemment il était de salut public
d'interdire ces ces non médias C ces
chaînes de désinformation et je cdrico a
a été offusqué en disant mais enfin mon
gouvernement ne va pas ne va pas faire
une telle atteinte à la liberté
d'expression le 27 février 2022 du jour
au lendemain on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait plus de problème de liberté
d'expression la naïveté les démocraties
c'est ça le problème elles réagissent
parfois et d'ailleurs jusqu'à présent
elles ont gagné mais elles réagissent
tard et cette naïveté continue cette
naïveté continue euh troisème remarque
le plus grand danger c'est pas celui à
mon avis de la de de de l'influence
extérieure c'est celui de la menace qui
vient de
l'intérieur cette menace je parle pas
d'une menace sur le plan de de la
désinformation mais Obama disait les
réseaux sociaux disait dans atlantique
il y a pas très longtemps les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus la principale
menace contre nos démocratie les réseaux
sociaux par leur abrutissement par leur
par l'ENS de de de de ce qu'il
représente je je pas la peine de faire
de dessin ici tout le monde le sait et
il était pas le seul à le dire obamaing
ping il y a quelques mois disait un au
page de de de chef d'entreprise mais
vous êtes en train avec vos réseaux
sociaux nous nous
les parleit pas de censure bien sûr il y
a la censure des réseaux sociaux en
Chine mais il y a aussi des choses assez
intelligentes que nous ne faisons pas
qui ont pas de la censure c'est le
contrôle de l'utilisation des ne
serait-ce que des horaires des réseaux
sociaux pour les enfants eting expliqué
vous êtes en train de détr une
génération qui ne qui ne fait plus rien
en classe qui ne dort pas la nuit parce
qu'elle regarde les réseaux sociaux et
cetera nous nous les empêchons de nous
avons nous leur donnons une des horaires
pour les regarder et cetera et cetera
nous les
protégeons nous ne faisons rien de cela
je voudrais faire une dernière remarque
Michel Valy qui est là et moi-même avons
fait récemment rendu un rapport sur
TikTok le rapport s'appelle la tactique
TikTok opacité addiction et ombres
chinoises et nous terminions ce rapport
en disant il y a des mesures de de santé
publique àendre des mesures de salubrité
publique qui est le contrôle de l'âge
qui est le contrôle de la modération et
cetera et nous sommes allés voir le
ministre du numérique qui nous a dit oui
oui oui il y a pas de problème bien
entendu vous avez raison et on va faire
ça et cetera et puis d'ailleurs je
prépare une grande loi sur le numérique
qui est l'adaptation du
DSA l'adaptation du DSA en France et moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
dit Thierry Breton sur le DSA c'était un
espoir le DSA le DSA paru il donnait
jusqu'au mois d'août aux plateformes
pour se mettre en conformité avec toutes
les recommandations la recommandation
principale breton l'avait très très bien
résumé tout ce qui est interdit hors
ligne doit être interdit en ligne ça
paraît vraiment de bon sens c'est
absolument le contraire qui se passe
aujourd'hui le rgpd n'avait rien réglé
le DSA ben on le voit maintenant c'est
il a été mis en place le mois d'août
s'est passé et aujourd'hui vous avez
vous-même tout à l'heure expliqué ce ce
qui se passe sur TikTok en prenant en
prenant un exemple on pourrait en
prendre des milliers ça ça ne fait que
se que que s'aggraver
euh alors voilà tout cela participe
d'une grande naïveté moi je voudrais je
pense que la question qui se pose euh
c'est la question que poser l'énine que
faire euh parce que la tâche est la
tâche est gantesque elle est à
l'extérieur elle est à l'intérieur et on
et on part avec un handicap considérable
les les les dictatures sont de retour on
les a cru mortes en 90 dans les années
90 on avait cru que le 20e siècle était
le siècle la lutte à mort entre les
démocraties et les dictatures Séta
terminé par la par la victoire des
démocraties on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
que c'est pas vrai que c'est même le la
tendance inverse qui se passe et on en
est presque aujourd'hui à espérer et
d'ailleurs l'exemple de Rean que j'ai
pris tout à l'heure montre que le pire
n'est pas toujours sûr on est on en est
à espérer que les dictatures elle-même
soit en train de commettre des erreurs
peut-être pire que les nôtres la guerre
en Ukraine et pour Poutine qu'il la
gagne ou qu'il la perde une erreur
considérable qui va affaiblir le clan
des dictatures la situation en Chine on
est en train de s'en apercevoir et du
point de vue démographique économique et
cetera beaucoup moins bonne qu'on le
penser l'Iran est en proid voilà le clan
des dictateurs s'est reformé mais en
temps le clan des dictateurs ne va pas
beaucoup mieux que le que les
démocraties je voudrais vous poser une
enfin une dernière question j'avais
présenté ici euh au Sénat un amendement
euh qui a été voté à l'unanimité et qui
disait
les en schématiquement euh dans la
querelle sur dans la polémique sur les
éditeurs et les hébergeurs vous savez
que les plateformes disent nous ne
sommes pas des éditeurs nous sommes des
hébergeurs donc nous n'avons pas de
responsabilité euh le Sénat a voté cet
amendement qui disait en substance à
partir du moment où une
plateforme trie l'information qu'elle
reçoit de ses abonnés
par des algorithmes elle a un statut
d'éditeur et non pas un statut
d'hébergeur si vous votez si si on vote
cette loi ça veut dire que les les les
plateformes deviennent responsables
alors qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
irresponsables et que toute la source du
problème est là évidemment cette cet
amendement voté à l'unanimité au Sénat
n'a pas été présenté à l'Assemblée
nationale ne sera pas présenté par le
gouvernement je voulais vous demander ce
que vous pensez de cela quand je dis que
faire bien entendu il y a beaucoup
d'autres questions si vous avez des
réponses mais sur ce sujet particul
j'aimerais bien votre je suis désolé
d'avoir été beaucoup trop long non mais
le propos est intéressant ma liste de
questions c'est'est un petit peu agrandi
je vais peut-être donner la parole à
Michel Valy qui l'a demandé et qui est
le second rapporteur du rapport
TikTok
Michel bon oui moi je suis corapporteur
sur le cyber mais je nai fait que
présider la commission d'enquête TikTok
dans claude miur était et le rapporteur
et l'initiateur surtout et qui a suivi
ça c'est important que le Dison soit
capté parce que je commence par dire que
Claude maluret a cité lesénine ça
restera au
compte-rendu des travaux du du Sénat
euh vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le
parallèle avec avec les questions de
virus lorsque nous tomb dessus un virus
dont dont on ne on n'attendait pas
l'ampleur et auquel on nétait pas
préparé dans la vie quotidienne et bien
en très peu de temps on explique aux
gens et on fait de la pédagogie de
manière générale pour expliquer pour
pourquoi les masques pourquoi le contact
comment ça circule quels sont les bons
gestes barrières comment on s'organise
pour pouvoir sortir pas sortir et le
message passe puisque l'un dans l'autre
d'un point de vue de l'ordre public on
peut penser ce qu'on veut he des mesures
qui ont été mis en œuvre mais en tout
cas elles ont été plus ou moins respecté
donc la pédagogie est le premier élément
essentiel vous avez parlé de des États
étrangers vous avez parlé de la façon
dont on s'organise sur viginum le com
cber et cetera vous avez répondu la
question que j'avais sur viginum mais là
se pose aussi une question de très long
terme qui est celle de l'éducation ouis
on a vite su tous parce que les
biologistes les épidémiologistes nous
ont expliqué comment fonctionnait ce
virus mais on ne sait pas comment
fonctionne notre cerveau ou on le sait
trop peu en terme de vulgarisation
scientifique ce sont des choses qui
passent assez alors il y a notamment des
télévisions de service public comme é
qui ont essayé de faire de la pédagogie
là-dessus avec des petites capsules
vidéo qui ont bien fonctionner c'est un
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan les
questions de plasticité cérébrale la
façon dont nous réagissons le fait que
on a pu l'entendre dans les auditions
lors de la commission TikTok même si
vous êtes un peu outillé en terme de
raison de raison critique euh une fausse
information une première fois vous
arrivez à la balayer une deuxième fois
si vous la prenez toute la journée 50
100 fois mécaniquement et de manière
scientifique par rapport aux questions
de plasticité cérébrale que nous
expliquent les neuros scientifique ça
finit par pénétrer et on finit par se
dire je résume il y a pas de fumée sans
feu euh il y a des scientifiques qui
travaillent très sérieusement de manière
mondiale sur des des coortes avec du
recul on les a auditionné pendant la
commission TikTok en ce moment sur les
infox et les premiers résultats montrent
que quand on explique à des Cortes
d'enfants euh dans un cadre éducatif à
l'école ou au collège que voilà ce que
c'est qu'une inf comment il faut
vérifier la source et cetera et bien un
des premiers effets constatés c'est
qu'ils en viennent à douter de
tout parce que quand on met en place des
mécanismes de défense on a cette
difficultélà donc ma question ma
première question est la suivante est-ce
que un des enjeux au-delà des questions
de défense cyber la technique c'est pas
l'éducation et est-ce qu'on a les moyens
en termes financiers de mettre en œuvre
quasiment une nouvelle matière en terme
éducatif qui va au-delà de l'éducation
morale et civique et qui est vraiment
d'outiller nos citoyens pour les rendre
libres 2e question euh on peut parler
des étrangers on peut parler de notre
naïveté mais déjà avant d'aller sur les
réseaux sociaux n'a-t-on pas commis une
erreur fondamentale dans la façon dont
nous avons payé je veux dire les les
pouvoir public et l'État un réseau qui
s'appelle la TNT qui a introduit dans
tous les foyers euh 18 20 ou 25 chaînes
quand on en avait euh 5 ou 6 et où c'est
une opinion personnelle sera peut-être
pas partagé par tout le monde quand même
quand vous zappez un peu vous vous
rendez compte où vous avez l'impression
que la France est un endroit où euh
votre voisin est un criminel en
puissance puisque vous n'avez que des
documentaires sur les questions de crime
euh vous hésitez à sortir la rue dans
dans la rue l'été au Cap d'AGD ou
ailleurs parce que vous avez constamment
des reportages sur la police municipale
au Cap d'AG ou que sais-je avec des
trucs complètement anxiogène on a des
émissions de télévision où les gens s'en
mettent plein la figure en permanence
c'est ce sont des canaux publics c'est
que c'est nous qui devrions choisir à
qui on confie ça est-ce que dans notre
naïveté collective il y a pas aussi ce
premier sujet-l moi je vais citer
Poutine puisque Claude maluré citait
Lénine quelque chose qui n'est pas passé
à la télévision n'a pas existé et bien
nous si on ne voit à la télévision que
des choses qui ne sont marginales dans
la vraie vie on finit par croire qu'on
vit tous dans un quartier où la BAC
intervient avec le voisin qui se fait
arnaquer merci Julien Courbet et le le
voisin d' en face sur le palier qui est
un tueur en série en puissance et qui
pourtant était un voisin sans
histoire merci monessieur les sénateur
pour pour vos questions s'agissant des
des premières qui qui m'ont été posées
je vais répondre à la question là plus
facile pour moi qui est la question
hébergeur ou éditeur pour moi comme
spécialiste de de de la propagande il ne
fait aucun doute et spécialistes de la
propagande numérique il ne fait aucun
doute qu'il ne peuvent prétendre des
hébergeurs ils sont des éditeurs à
partir du moment où il hiérarchisent le
contenu ou par exemple l'actuel
propriétaire de X Twitter a choisi de
baisser le nombre de personnes qui
pouvaient être touché par les
publications du New York Times et
augmenter de façon drastique le nombre
de personnes qui peuvent être touché par
des publications à caractère antisémite
nous sommes en présence d'un choix
éditorial nous sommes en présence d'un
éditeur de contenu et devrait être
traité comme tel euh en ce qui concerne
ensuite ce que vous disiez de Ronald
Rean je voudrais juste quand même rendre
euh ce qui lui est dû au renseignement
français euh qui en traitant une source
en Russie a permis à notre président
d'Alor François mitteran de transmettre
des informations à régan sur l'état réel
de l'économie russe qui ont pu euh
l'aider dans ses prises de décisions et
dans et et dans et dans ses choix mais
plus euh plus fondamentalement ce à quoi
vous avez fait référence c'est c'est la
guerre cognitive c'est là nous disent de
façon très publique les dirigeants de
l'Armée populaire de libération de la
République populaire de Chine c'est là
que se trouve le le théâtre de combat
ultime des nations au 21e siècle à
l'intérieur même du
cerveau de nos concitoyens et c'est la
raison pour laquelle des investissements
considérables sont fait par ces acteurs
notamment par la Chine pour pénétrer
l'esprit de nos concitoyens vous citiez
TikTok bien évidemment qui est une porte
d'entrée à la fois majeure et
particulièrement inquiétante mais il y
en a d'autres un récent rapport publié
le 3 septembre M semble-t-il de
Microsoft indique que parmi tous les
influenceurs qui sont financés par le
ministère des Affaires étrangères
chinois en Europe les plus nombreux sont
les Français et qu'en recrutant des
influenceurs français francophones il
s'agit aussi d'achever de réduire
l'influence de la France en Afrique dans
l'océan Indien il y a une entreprise de
déstabilisation à l'égard de notre pays
qui est manifeste et qui est même pas
dissimulée les toutes les doctrines
militaires de la Chine de la Russie sont
disponibles en ligne toutes les
adaptations qui sont faites aujourd'hui
par les doctrine militaire occidentale
celle du Pentagone il y a quelques jours
celle de l'OTAN qui est en train d'être
euh d'évoluer sont également disponibles
et montrent qu'il y a une prise de
conscience euh mondiale de la euh
gravité inédite de l'intensité inédite
de la menace cognitive chinoise dans
toutes les dimensions s'agissant de
l'information oui monsieur le sénateur
je suis d'accord avec vous nous faisons
face à une infodémie et face à cette
infodémie il nous faut quelque part
sortir d'autres cloisonnements qui sont
là des cloisonnements universitair et
scientifiqu français dans mes différents
livres que je consacre à au parcours de
manipulateur de masse je constate
souvent qu'ils ont des parcours qui sont
inenvisageables en France ils sont ils
font de la physique nucléaire et ensuite
de l'inform informtique où ils font de
l'informatique et de la psychanalyse ou
de la psychologie sociale ils font ils
font certaines disciplines qui
aujourd'hui en France sont très
dévalorisées comme la psychologie sont
des disciplines absolument cruciales et
centrales dans d'autres pays notamment
dans l'entourage de Monsieur Zuckerberg
il y a nombre de psychologues des
psychologues dont ceux que vous avez
auditionné sont régulièrement consulté
par telle ou telle plateforme pour les
aider à faire face à ce phénomène
d'infodémie donc il il nous faut avoir
une approche globale aussi en terme
scientifique et accepter de faire euh
discuter et dialoguer des scientifiques
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de dialoguer je
cache pas que pour ma part parmi les
scientifiques que je côtoie celui qui
m'apporte le plus est un mathématicien
David chavalarias qui a énormément de
talents et dont l'un des talents est de
rendre visible ces phénomènes qui sont
invisibles ces phénomènes d'interaction
sur les réseaux sociaux où il rend euh
visible c'est ce ce virus informationnel
euh sur sur Twitter en particulier
s'agissant de l'éducation oui bien
évidemment il faut éduquer comme le fait
taiïwan comme le font nombre de pays
comme le fait la Finlande comme le fait
la Suède il faut éduquer nos enfants dès
le plus jeune âge non pas tant à un
scepticisme à l'égard de l'information
mais à une démarche constructive qui
consiste d'une part à leur expliquer
comment on construit l'information
comment on distingue le vrai du faux et
comment certains peuvent chercher à
affaiblir la distinction entre le vrai
du faux pour les tromper une des
démarches cognitivistes qui me paraît la
plus porteuse d'espoir aujourd'hui est
celle d'un laboratoire de l'université
de Cambridge d'où sont sorties certaines
des innovations les plus dommageables
pour l'histoire de l'humanité je parle
de celles qui ont été exploité par
Cambridge Analytica et par le
renseignement militaire russe à partir
de 2014 donc dans un autre laboratoire
quelqu'un qui est du côté clair de la
force et non du côté obscur qui
s'appelle Sander V Linden travaille à
l'élaboration de de vaccins
psychonologiqu vous savez dans la dans
dans dans l'analyse traditionnelle de la
propagande il y avait ce que l'on
appelait à partir de 1937 la vaccine
vous allez atténuer une information qui
vous est dommageable en devançant en
quelque sorte l'arrivée de cette
information par un petit élément
d'information qui va atténuer la portée
de la même façon que c'est une souche
affaiblie du virus qui est à l'origine
du vaccin du vaccin traditionnel donc
une souche affaiblie de désinformation
pour renforcer le système immunitaire
des individus eux-mêmes face à
l'information nous en avons je crois
grand besoin et
enfin l'OCDE s'est emparé de ces
questions a créé un groupe expert sur
les manipulations de l'information qui a
tenu une première réunion publique
récemment l'OCDE a lancé aussi des
initiatives pour collecter les
initiatives prises par ces différents
États-membres qui ont porté des fruits
et le secrétaire général de l'OCDE a une
formule qui me semble tout à fait
pertinente pour nous indiquer ce que
pourrait être la direction vers laquelle
collectivement nous pourrions aller il
substitue au free flow of information à
la libre circulation de l'information
qui était l'approche traditionnelle des
États-Unis depuis toujours le free flow
of trusted
la libre circulation d'information
fiable ce vers quoi nous devons tendre
c'est une réflexion collective sur le
cadre et les modalités d'une diffusion
libre
d'information fiable pour répondre à
l'infodmis par une diffusion aussi
massive que possible d'une information à
même de faire face à la défiance vous
savez pour terminer sur RT lorsqu'il y a
eu l'interdiction je fus l'un des rares
à parmi les chercheurs à m'exprimer
publiquement en faveur de cette
interdiction au nom de ce que j'appelais
l'état d'urgence informationnelle
c'était un état d'urgence il fallait
prendre des mesures et cette mesure me
paraissait justifiée rétrospectivement
le même chercheur que je suis fait le
constat que cette mesure non seulement a
été sans effet puisque l'interdiction de
RT ne s'est pas traduite par
l'interdiction des facto de l'accès à
ces contenus que ces contenus ont
continué de circuler euh soit par le
recours à des VPN et aux consultations
sur le web soit par la diffusion massive
de ces contenus par des vidéos sur
YouTube et au passage permettez-moi de
relever le fait que s'agissant de RT le
modèle de diffusion privilégié à
l'échelle mondiale par sa sa rédactrice
en chef qu' repose sur une diffusion
micro ciblée sur les médias sociaux et
non pas sur un nombre de téléspectateurs
devant le écran donc l'interdiction de
la chaîne sur l'écran ne change
pratiquement rien mais surtout tout
l'interdiction de RT je le constate à
chaque fois que je fais des conférences
publiques a eu pour effet de conforter
la défiance d'un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens d'encourager une défiance à
l'égard de ceux qui ont pris cette
mesure qui est interprétée comme une
mesure liberticide et qu'il est possible
d'expliquer mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile c'est de faire face à
cette défiance tandis que lorsque ces
mêmes personnes y compris des gens qui
sont adeptes de de théories du complot
vraiment déconnectés de touteé réalité
entendre un discours qui repose sur les
fondements mêmes de notre République la
liberté à commencé par la liberté
d'expression la liberté
d'opinion la discussion est leur est
beaucoup moins favorable et sommme
toutes si quelqu'un veut chanter les
jouanges de Vladimir Poutine ou affirmer
que la terre est plate il en a le droit
ce qui est plus problématique pour nous
c'est lorsque ce discours est
artificiellement amplifié relayé porte
aussi par des agents d'influence
financés par le cremelin qui lui donnent
une place tout à fait disproportionnée
dans notre espace informationnel
et nos démocraties je pense ont les
moyens d'assumer leur force par la force
de leur liberté de leur modèle c'est ma
conviction de citoyen en même temps que
de
chercheur merci je vous propose de
prendre en série les trois dernières
questions comme ça ce sera trois rép
c'est votre conclusion si vous le voulez
bien monsieur le professeur la parole
est à Giselle Jourda merci monsieur le
Président alors non je n'évoquerai pas
les pays qui nous sont chers au
président et à moi-même à savoir vous
les avez évoqué la Chine avec
donc dont on minimiser l'impact il y a
du Parti communiste chinois mais dont on
a vu le le le grand combat qu'avec les
routes de la soie qui nous ont chè et
que nous avons particulièrement étudié
euh en revanche vous vous citez donc les
États-Unis vous citez la Chine vous
citez donc la Russie en ce qui concerne
la la Russie moi j'aimerais savoir si
vous avez une idée de l'ampleur de
l'implication de l'appareil
désinformationnel russes dans le conflit
actuel au
prochorian mais euh vous évoquez donc
ces États-Unis donc Chine donc et Russie
cuit de l'Inde dans dans cette guerre
don de l'information don vous dites
qu'elle n'a ni début ni fin quelle est
donc son implication parce qu'on voit
quand même l'Inde en pointe sur dans
beaucoup de sujets que ce soit sur la
stratégie du spatial et cetera on la
voit quand même arriver sur les marchés
quel est votre sentiment sur ce sujet-là
et en et une autre partie de ma question
mais elle a été vous y avez répondu
puisque le le monsieur le ministre
maluré l'a
évoqué avait tras au propos de Thierry
Breton par rapport donc à la création de
d'un réseau donc BluSky donc j'aurais
voulu connaître donc votre opinion sur
sa sur sa faisabilité pardon excusez ma
voix un peu un peu difficile
ensuite euh je finirai donc mon
questionnement sur
euh les propos donc et l'engagement de
notre du président de la République il a
a fait donc de l'influence un objectif
stratégique de notre défense et sécurité
nationale il y a bien une prise de
conscience mais le problème est de
savoir avec quels outils une démocratie
peut s'engager dans une guerre de
l'information on a vu que nos médias RFI
ou France 24 refusent d'être perçus
comme des outils de notre influence
quelle méthode la France peut-elle
employer à votre
sentiment merci Giselle je passe la
parole à Alain houper
voilà merci
Président je crois que dans il y a rien
de pire dans l'histoire que les trous de
mémoire on oppose toujours le bien et le
mal mais qu'est-ce que le bien et
qu'est-ce que le mal il y a le problème
de la parole officielle souvenez-vous de
la guerre du golf où il y a une
manipulation mondiale de de colline Paul
Wells de George buouch sur les armes de
destruction massive et heureusement et
là j'étais fier d'être français de
d'avoir un Premier ministre Dominique de
Villepin se faire quasiment traiter de
menteur par le reste du monde entier
donc la parole officielle elle est
importante
mais faut-il défendre on est
toujours fort contre le faible et faible
contre le fort et là vous avez parlé des
printemps arabe cette guerre
2.0 mais les printemps arabes c'est le
résultat de la guerre du Golfe c'est
aussi le résultat de l'action française
quand on est allé chercher
roménie en Libye c'est le résultat de
l'histoire n'oublions pas tout ça
et la manipulation a toujours existé
souvenez-vous de du président
Horwood Wilson le Pacifique qui s'est
servi de grandes personnes de la
communication comme Bernard bernes pour
faire changer l'opinion américains qui
étaient très pacifique et qui ne voulait
pas entrer dans la première guerre
mondiale et heureusement pour nous mais
la manipulation elle est partout et pour
en terminer souvenons-vous la République
française elle vient d'une révolution
une révolution qui a commencé par par
des réseaux sociaux de l'époque qui
s'appelaient les libelles et les libell
c'était nos grands écrivains comme
mIRABO au risque de leur vie qu'on
balancer dans la population parisienne
des des petites affiches pour réveiller
ceux qui ne savaient pas et grâce à ces
libells grâce à ces petits réseaux
sociaux on a eu la Révolution française
on a eu la République
française
question
éch large Valérie Boer merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président je vais
essayer d'être bref parce que j'ai trois
petites questions à vous poser tout à
l'heure mes collègues ont évoqué
effectivement un réseau extrêmement
puissant qui a
déstabilisé nos démocraties et qui était
extrêmement bien organisé qui continu à
l'être c'est celui du Parti communiste
c'est vrai qu'il y avait tout les
universités les grands acteurs
dont on célèbre bientôt je crois qu'il y
a un spectacle à la gloire de l'un
d'entre eux des des journaux qui
continuent à exister euh où
effectivement il était difficile de de
de résister à cette propagande y compris
même des des petits journaux pour les
enfants comme Pif Gadget et aujourd'hui
on a un petit peu la même chose que avec
le wisme et vous n'avez pas évoqué cette
ce ce mouvement extrêmement
important où on assiste et c'est ma
première question aujourd'hui puisque
vous avez vu
que sur le plan économique le wisme est
sanctionné par les consommateurs si on
peut en juger par la déroute de de Walt
Disney qui revient sur sa politique
alors que en politique il est
imposé aux démocraties de façon parfois
très violente on voit ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis on voit même ce qui se
passe parfois chez nous également et
c'est ma première question pourquoi vous
n'avez pas évoqué le wid ma deuxième
question c'est que vous avez parlé de
l'influence bien évidemment euh et une
affaire qui moi m'a beaucoup secoué je
dois dire c'est c'est l'arrestation
d'une journaliste grecque et d'autres
personnes qui avaiit subi l'influence au
niveau des instances européennes du
Qatar et et du Maroc et on a plus du
tout entendu parler de cette affaire
mais on sait bien qu'on a trouvé alors
là c'était pas des valises de Bignet
mais des baignoirs de billet
chez elle et chez d'autres justement
pour qu'elle puisse pour qu'elle puisse
en tout cas c'est la police belge qui
avait trouvé ça pour qu'elle puisse
influencer de quelle façon et ma
troisème question pourquoi on ne parle
pas de ça parce que je pense que c'est
très important au niveau de nos
instances les influences via les réseaux
sociaux via des via aussi enfin tout ça
est très relayé et ma troisième question
vous avez parlé de l'interdiction de RT
ouais d'ACT pourquoi on parle pas
d'alkaïda aujourd'hui jira et d'aljazira
excusez-moi quel lapsus
d'aljzira bien ben voilà Monsieur le
Professeur je vous propose de répondre à
cette dernière série de questions et de
nous livrer votre conclusion merci à
vous merci je vais vous répondre aussi
brèvement que possible d'abord en ce qui
concerne la Russie je répondrai par la
même occasion à la question qui porte
sur le wisme la Russie en réalité euh
depuis euh très longtemps a constitué un
un réseau d'information vous faisiez
référence au mouvement de la liberté aux
interactions avec les partis communistes
à l'étranger du temps de la guerre
froide un réseau d'ONG un réseau
d'experts de soutien qui demeure très
vivant aujourd'hui il y a de très
nombreux soutiens de la Russie dans des
environnements français à à grande
échelle et pour le sujet qui est le mien
qui est celui des ingérences étrangères
je je ferais remarquer que il y a un axe
aujourd'hui de de désinformation qui est
un axe qui unit la Russie l'Iran la
Chine et leurs alliés respectifs Corée
du Nord la Syrie de Bachar
al-Assad le hzbollah notamment et cet
axe est un axe contrefactuel
c'est-à-dire que c'est une grande
communauté d'information euh
contrefactuelle qui s'emploie à diffuser
des informations pour contrer
l'information officielle et présenter
une multitude de vérités alternatives
sans toujours avoir de souci de
cohérence quant au récit alternatif qui
est construit c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit
davantage de déconstruire que de
construire un réel discours alternatif
et nous sommes ici en présence d'acteurs
qui s'emploie depuis longtemps à
instrumentaliser toutes les failles
préexistantes de nos sociétés et là où
des failles n'existaient pas à en créer
de nous nouvelle et de mon point de vue
la question du bokisme s'inscrit dans
cette perspective c'est-à-dire que il y
a s'agissant de la Russie pour ne
prendre que cet exemple une stratégie de
long terme qui date déjà de la guerre
froide et consistante à instrumentaliser
les revendication des minorités quel que
soit le type de minorité en question
d'instrumentaliser toutes les
dénonciation des inégalités ou du
racisme par exemple dans les sociétés
occidentale pour
approfondir et creuser les les divisions
vous avez cité le Qatar il ne fait aucun
doute que le Qatar est aujourd'hui un
acteur majeur d'ingérance non seulement
en France mais dans de nombreux autres
pays avec des relais qui sont des relais
parfois
extrêmement
extrêmement bruyants et je pense qu'une
loi de transparence en matière
d'ingérence étrangère comparable au
Phara des
États-Unis serait de nature à nous
permettre
d'avoir des faits sur lesquels s'appuyer
si l'on pouvait quantifier tout
simplement cette ingérence cela
conduirait je crois à une prise de
conscience et peut-être la mobilisation
de certains esprits il est important
quand des gens s'expriment notamment sur
les chaînes de télévision de savoir d'où
ils parlent s'ils sont ou non financer
directement ou indirectement qui par la
Chine qui par le Qatar qui par le
kremelin euh qui par un autre un autre
État s'agissant de l'Inde je ne me suis
pas effectivement focalisé sur cette
question dans la mesure où mon livre
traite de cette guerre de 30 ans entre
les démocraties et les régimes
autoritaires et en l'espèce il
m'apparaît que dans le domaine
cybernétique l'un est d'abord l'endroit
où l'on trouve beaucoup de gens qui
vendent des services euh qui sont
utilisés par les uns et les autres aussi
bien des services de support
informatique que des services de
trolling des services de modération et
je n'ai pas mais c'est peut-être une
faiblesse de ma part je n'ai pas
identifié de la part de l'Inde de
véléité agressive à l'égard de nos
démocraties occidentales vous avez
mentionner cet échange assez surréaliste
entre notre commissaire européen Thierry
Breton et Elon Musk sur Twitter lorsque
Monsieur breton rappelait à Elon Musk
quellesétaient ses obligations au titre
des règlements européens et du DSA et
que il a fini par inviter les
utilisateurs de Twitter mécontent de
Twitter à aller sur Blu Sky qui est un
réseau auquel on ne peut accéder pour
l'heure que sur invitation et qui est
effectivement un espèce de paradis des
journalistes et des experts où vous ne
risquez pas d'être trollé d'être
confronté à de l'agressivité à de la
désinformation ou à des bottes euh pas
de tout cas en de grande ampleur et il
me semble en l'occurrence que euh
monsieur breton aurait pu faire suivre
sa déclaration des faits avec l'ouver la
création d'un serveur européen
accessible à tous financé sur fond
public et qui nous permettrait de mettre
les esprits de nos enfants en
particulier à l'abri des ingérences
étrangères vous savez j'ai j'ai deux
deux filles à l'école elles sont toutes
petites la plus grande à 7 ans et à 7
ans la question qui commence à se poser
déjà est celle du télé portable et sur
les téléphones portables des plus grands
de CM1 et de CM2 qu'est-ce que l'on voit
on voit TikTok et sur les écrans de
TikTok qu'est-ce que l'on voit on voit
ce que Monsieur le Ministre maluret
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire une
volonté manifeste de subvertir les
esprits d'encourager la violence
d'exposer ses enfants à la pornographie
de les exposer à la violence de les
exposer à la propagande de de fragiliser
c'est effectivement un enjeu sanitaire
avant d'être un enjeu un enjeu de de de
de souveraineté s'agissant de la
remarque que vous faisiez tout à l'heure
s'agiss à propos de la parole officielle
il est certain que le fait que nos
démocraties ait pu mentir et manipuler
l'opinion publique mondiale n'a pas
rendu service sur le long terme à nos
démocraties les États-Unis n'ont rien
gagné à manipuler l'opinion publique
mondiale comme ils l'ont fait en 2003 au
moment de l'entrée en guerre et cela
doit être pour nous un enseignement à
savoir qu'une démocratie ne doit pas euh
mener des opérations de manipulation de
l'information ni parrainer des
opérations de manipulation de
l'information et je me réjouis pour ma
part de de voir que la la France a signé
la déclaration mondiale pour l'intégrité
de
l'information qui a été lancée à l'ONU
en septembre dernier et qui fait
notamment obligation enfin dans lesquel
les pays signataires s'engage à ne pas
mener de telles opérations de
manipulation de l'information parce que
vous savez j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
la distinction entrem entre le vrai et
le faux et cette volonté des régimes
autoritaires d'affaiblir notre régime de
vérité et toute distinction entre le
vrai et les faux pour
conclure je voudrais
Infiné insister sur le fait que ce qui
est également en jeu ici c'est la
distinction entre ce qu'est une
démocratie et ce qu'est un régime
autoritaire si par notre réaction face
au manipul de l'information nous en
venons volontairement ou non à brouiller
cette distinction entre une démocratie
et un régime
autoritaire nous ne ferons que conforter
en définitive les régimes autoritaires
qui attendent précisément de nous cela
ils attendent précisément de nous que
nous portions atteinte à notre régime de
liberté ils attendent précisément de
nous que nous renforcions les la
défiance à l'égard des institutions
publiques par l'adoption de mesures
contraignantes ou liberticide nous avons
plus que jamais besoin de nous défendre
par notre modèle et par la liberté et
une dernière fois je vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir bien voulu m'écouter
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux d'avoir
participé à cette audition bien monsieur
le professeur
merci excusez-moi monsieur le Président
je voulais juste savoir quelle était la
différence pour Monsieur entre RT et
aljazira pour moi il me semble que il
n'y en a pas dans la mesure où aljazira
apparaît très clairement comme un média
d'État m'apparaît comme un média d'État
je peux me tromper
mais probablement pas comme un média de
service
public voilà qui est clair monsieur le
professeur merci d'avoir consacré
d'avoir consacré du temps à notre à
notre
commission juste deux
choses premier élément Jisel jourdda n'a
pas voulu l'évoquer tout à l'heure
c'est pas anecdotique vous avez évoqué
les les recrutements d'agents
francophones par les Chinois lors de
notre premier rapport sur les routes de
la soie on a fait un déplacement en
Chine et nous avons visité une
université qui n'est pas une université
au sens où nous l'entendons nous puisque
il y a des élèves qu' ont 4 ou 5 ans et
les plus âgés sont en fin d'étude à 22
23 ans avec cette particularité que tout
se faisait en français et en fait nous
avons rencontrit de de jeunes enfants
classe de CP CE et cetera qui nous
récitaent des poèmes où nous chantai des
petites chansons en français les plus
grands nous parlaient des matières
qu'ils étudiaient et effectivement les
étudiants qui étaient dans la
technologie dans l'ingénierie et cetera
nous exposai aussi leur matière et en
fait quel était l'avenir de de de ces
Cortes de de de de de jeunes en
formation bien pour les plus plus
talentueux c'était effectivement d'être
affecté en France et pour ceux qui l'
étaient peut-être un peu moins mais qui
étaient quand même bien formé c'était
d'être les encadrants chinois dans
l'Afrique francophone bien quand on
imagine des systèmes de formation comme
ça c'est quand même extrêmement
impressionnant et c'était en 2018 si ma
mémoire si ma mémoire est bonne la
phrase d'un de ces étudiants qui une de
ses dernières interventions a été mais
comment se peut-il que niveau de
l'information puiss on puisse critiquer
le pouvoir en place dans les démocraties
moi ça m'avait énormément choqué donc
voilà c'est c'est pas totalement une
anecdote mais c'est un petit peu d'eau à
notre à notre moulin collectif et pour
pour pour conclure donc vous remercie de
de de votre présence m mes chers
collègues vous remerciez aussi de la
qualité de ces échanges vous avez pu
remarquer qu'on travaille ici dans le
temps long et effectivement le sujet qui
nous a préoccupé ce matin n'est
effectivement pas un sujet nouveau mais
je crois réellement qu'il s'accélère en
fait et les moyens technologiques qui se
développent et qui se développent et on
a probablement pas encore tout vu ne
vont faire qu'accélérer le le le le
problème moi ce que je retiens quand
même de ces échanges c'est que quand on
parle du bien et du mal on est toujours
sur une ligne de crête et qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de de de de de de
déterminer ement en fonction des points
de vue des uns et des autres ce que peut
être le bien et le mal et et la
conséquence aussi parce que là on est
bien installé on a tous je crois un
certain niveau d'information mais vous
l'avez évoqué c'est qu'une fois qu'on a
tiré nos propres conclusions comment les
partage-t-on avec la population et
comment peut-on amener les gens à
comprendre qu'à un moment donné il faut
bien réguler tout cela sans que ce soit
liberticide et je crois que la grande
ulté de l'exercice ça va être celle-là
et cette guerre là n'est pas gagnée je
vous remercie il y a pas de questions
diverses donc je lève la
séance